under attack
and under siege
this police station in the center of
bristol became the focus of violence
thousands had illegally gathered to
demonstrate against the police in crime
bill
concerned about their freedom to protest
but it quickly got out of control
i think it was important to be down here
when things were peaceful
because the right to protest is crucial
to any democracy obviously
this however is a little bit
embarrassing i think for the city of
bristol
this is not a peaceful protest this is
just going to be used against us
and as evidence to keep our rights
process away from us
two police officers were taken to
hospital one with a broken arm
another broken ribs the police have now
pushed forward the protest line
from the front of the police station
where the windows have been smashed
they've pushed the protesters
further back here there's around two or
three hundred still remaining
condemnation has been widespread home
secretary pretty patel said on twitter
that the scenes in bristol were
unacceptable thuggery and disorder
by a minority will never be tolerated
she added
while bristol's mayor marvin reeves said
while he understands frustrations
smashing buildings in our city center
vandalizing vehicles
attacking our police will do nothing to
lessen the likelihood
of the bill going through the scenes in
bristol
are reminiscent of the london riots
violence that will be a concern
for forces across the country it's the
genuine concern within policing that
similar protests against his police in
crimeville maybe maybe
carried out across the country and i
think that today police forces will be
looking at their
responses to these types of protests the
intelligence information they've got on
them
and their capability to react to fast
moving and spontaneous public disorder
and criminal
criminal offences that we see take place
the disorder is meters away from where
the statue of slave trader edward
colston
was pulled down last summer protests in
bristol
are back in the spotlight police say
there will be significant consequences
for those involved dan white is sky news
in bristol